Metro Police investigating a series of
burglaries on the far west side of town
thank you for joining us at six I'm
Kirsten joy and I'm Brian Loftus the
area is targeted Queens Ridge and
Piccoli Ranch Madison Kimbrough live
near Charleston in Hualapai Madison with
a story you'll only see here on 8 News
Now
we are in front of Queens Ridge Estates
and as you can see behind me this is a
guard gated community but that didn't
stop criminals from getting in and
invading homes and now residents in and
around the area are on high alert
feel very uncomfortable you know
being that we're not safe in our homes
over here residents in the Queens Ridge
and Piccoli Ranch neighborhoods voicing
concern over what police are calling a
Summerlin burglary series as multiple
houses
most recently and even scarier situation
in the Queen's Ridge Estates reports of
a home invasion led to a potential
drowning of an elderly woman residents
like Andrew lynchburger approached by
Metro with this information and the
security guard at the Gate of the
Estates confirming that information with
8 news now they said that there was a
home invasion burglary and some sort of
torture that happened to an elderly
couple they're in critical care
apparently they accessed the queensridge
development through the tunnel system
fellow neighbor was steli Regalado says
Metro alerted his family since the
criminals were said to have been parked
on their street before attempting to
cross Charleston to get into queensridge
Estates the Metro approach your house
was checking to see which houses had
cameras facing certain Street angles
apparently in there were break-ins in
Queens Ridge and people that were doing
it were caught parking around bacoli
Ranch
as for other burglaries in the area
Regalado tells me he had his car broken
into recently I also spoke with
Neighbors at the Tudor Park development
at Queen's Ridge who also say they've
seen their fair share of break-ins
recently too reporting near Charleston
and Hualapai Madison Kimbrough 8 news
now Madison thank you now because this
is an ongoing investigation Metro Police
could not provide any more additional
information